factor 27 X to the sixth plus 125 so
this is a pretty interesting problem and
frankly the only way to do this is if
you recognize it as a special form and
what I want to do is kind of show you
the special form right first and then we
can kind of pattern match so the special
form is if I were to take and this is
really just something you need to know
you know that I'd argue whether you
really need to know this but it actually
do this problem it's something you just
need to know and that's if you have a
squared minus a B plus B squared and you
multiply that times a plus B let's think
about what we're going to get so we're
going to take a product right here we're
multiplying so let's do some algebraic
multiplication so let's multiply B times
B squared it's B to the third B times
negative a B is negative a B squared B
times a squared is a squared B now let's
multiply this top term times a a times B
squared is a b squared a times negative
a b is negative a squared B and then a
times a squared is a to the third and
then we just have to add up all of the
terms we have a negative a squared B we
have a positive a squared being a
negative a squared B so these guys
cancel out we have a negative a B
squared and a positive a B squared these
guys cancel out so all we're left with
is an a to the third here and a to the
third and then plus plus this B to the
third plus this B to the third or
another way to think about it if someone
gives you a to the third plus B to the
third this can be factored into these
two expressions that can be factored
into a plus B times a squared minus a B
plus B squared so this is essentially
the special form if you have a sum of
cubes it can be factored out as the sum
of the the cube roots plus or the sum of
the cube roots times this expression
right here and we just showed that it
works so let's see if we have that
special form here
well 27 is definitely the cube of 3 3
the third power is 27 X to the sixth is
also the cube of x squared if you raise
X to the 6 to the 1/3 power you get x
squared so this first term right over
here can be rewritten as 3x squared to
the third power and the second term
right here that's 5 to the third power
so plus 5 to the third power and just
this might be a little bit confusing for
you so just let's never hurts to review
let's multiply 3x squared times 3x
squared times 3x the squared that is
literally equal to 3 times 3 times 3
times x squared times x squared times x
squared that's this part right here is
27 x squared times x squared is X to the
fourth times x squared is X to the sixth
or you could just raise both of these to
the third power 3 to the third is 27 x
squared to the third power you take an
exponent to an exponent and you're going
to take the product of the exponents so
it'll be X to the 2 times 3 or X to the
sixth power so now we know that we have
this pattern so we can just use this we
have the sum of cubes so just by using
this pattern right over here that means
that we can factor it as this is going
to be equal to 3x squared that's our a
let me make it clear this right here is
our a this right here is our B so it's
going to be a plus B so it's going to be
3x squared plus B plus 5 times a squared
a squared let me do this in a new color
so 3x squared squared let's write think
about that for a second 3x squared
squared well that's going to be 9x to
the fourth so it's going to be times 9x
to the fourth minus the product of these
two things so minus the product of 5 and
3x squared so minus 15 x squared and
then finally plus B squared B is 5 so
it's going to be 5 squared so plus 25
when I say B is that this is B not the
whole five to the third and when I say a
just this part is a and we're done and
we
I won't explain it in detail in this
video but this right here for thinking
about real numbers we can't actually
factor this anymore so we are done
factoring this and remember this is
really just a very very very special
case of being able to recognize the sum
the sum of cubes